>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>>Mary-Jane Deeb: Good afternoon.
Good afternoon ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of the
African-Middle East Division here
and I'm delighted to see you
all here, and we are, today,
co-sponsoring a wonderful program
with our speaker, Mr. Mehdi Saeedi,
who is a Persian designer
and visual artist,
and you probably already have
had glimpses of his work,
as he was going through the
images, and we're co-sponsoring,
as we have on a number of other
programs, we're cosponsoring this
with the University of Maryland,
with Roshan Center, and with Dr.
/ Professor Fatemeh Keshavarz,
who has been an inspiration
and a guiding light
in all our programs,
all our Persian programs
and many others.
She has been with us, a partner,
a friend, on our exhibit,
on the Persian book, and on
the series that we've had
since that exhibit, series on the
Persian book, Persian literature,
Persian philosophy, and this
year has been the visual arts,
the Persian visual arts.
Hence, the presence
of Mr. Mehdi Saeedi.
I always do this for our program.
I have to say a few things about
our division, and our division
in our reading room here,
our reading room is one
of the 21 reading rooms of
the Library of Congress.
This one is the one
that serves people,
collections from 78
different countries.
We have three sections,
the African section.
So it's the whole continent
of Africa.
We have a Middle East section,
which is quite expansionous,
which goes from Morocco to Oman.
That includes Iran and Turkey but
also Afghanistan, Central Asia,
and the Caucuses, as well
as communities in China
and in Russia and elsewhere.
The focus of our work is not only
that we recommend and acquire books
from all these regions of the
world, and we have a Arabic section,
as I mentioned, Arabic section.
We collect books from
around the world,
but the focus is on the vernacular.
That is, on the languages
of these regions.
In other words, for the
Arabic section, for example,
we collect in Hebrew,
in Yiddish, and Latino.
For the Mideast section, we
collect those materials that are
in the language of the region.
So Persian, Arabic,
Turkish, Armenian, Georgian,
and so many others, and
we collect them here,
meaning that these are the
collections that produce
from those countries about those
countries but by writers who write
in the languages of those countries,
and that's very important,
because we also have collections
in English and French and German
and Italian of other countries
of other 78 countries,
but these are part of
the general collection,
and we treasure these materials
which come from all over the world.
We have a big Preservation
Division that takes care of them.
We have manuscripts that
are taken care of as
if they were newborn babies.
We have materials that are
-- that no one else has,
and we also have regular
publications, books, serials,
journals, et cetera, and we work
cooperatively across the library.
So with divisions such as the
Geography and Map Division,
it has maps of these countries.
With Prints and Photographs,
it has photographs that go back
to the beginning of photography
about these countries.
With the Law Library that has
the gazettes and those materials.
So if you were to come here, you
would work across the library,
but this would be the area
also where the specialists are,
where the languages
are spoken and written,
and where we have brilliant people
that are Persian specialists.
Hirad Dinavari, who has been really
an incredible force in expanding,
developing our collections
and our programs.
We treasure our partners,
and we have been working
with the University of Maryland,
with Professor Keshavarz
for several years now,
and all for the good.
We have numerous projects with
them, and this is a way to reach
out to people, to young people who
want to learn about the regions
and the art and the culture of
the countries that we represent,
and we invite scholars, artists,
writers, thinkers to our division
to share with us their
ideas, their viewpoints,
their perspective,
and their research.
Now when they're addressing you,
they're not only addressing you,
they're addressing the world,
because we videotape our programs.
We put them on the
Library's website,
and then they are accessible across
the board, and I won't say forever,
but they're there permanently
on our website.
In other words, years from
now, people will still be able
to access today's speaker's
presentation.
He will be there because
this is the way.
We also advertise.
We now have blogs, and the program
has already appeared on our blog,
and I know on the University
of Maryland's blog, as well.
So we try to reach out to as
many people to get them involved
and to see what we
have as our treasures.
So I would like now to
introduce our partner.
Dr. Fatemeh Keshavarz, who is a
poet, a writer, a great scholar,
and as I was just telling
her lately, a dynamo in terms
of activities and at times of the
work she's been doing on Iran,
but let her talk about
her institution.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you
so much Mary-Jane and
welcome everybody.
It is an absolute pleasure
to have this collaboration.
We haven't found greater friends
than you guys here, and you know,
it's just mutual everything
you said.
I'm not going to take a lot of
time, because I know my dear friend,
Hirad, is going to
introduce the artist.
You're going to hear
from a first-class artist
with an amazing talent to
combine letters of the alphabet
and all kinds of artistic movements
and creative ways of
thinking about them.
So, you know, we will let
him speak about his work.
Let me just say that in
our traditions, that is,
I'm now thinking of Middle East
and Africa, an oral tradition,
an exchange of person-to-person,
has been always
at the foundation of
all the writing.
So while the writing
is so important,
there are these huge written
treasures that we have here.
The oral dimension of
something going from one person
to another has always been
honored as a great way of learning.
So we are absolutely
delighted at Roshan Institute
to have this opportunity here at
the Library of Congress to voice
that aspect of our learning
and looking forward to more.
Welcome again.
This is a hard time
of the day to be here.
So we appreciate all of you coming.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Everyone, thank
you very much for your patience.
I also want to add that
this is a joint effort
between three organizations.
Us, the Library of Congress,
University of Maryland,
Roshan Institute for
Persian Studies, as well,
as the [inaudible] Committee,
who has made this possible,
working with the wonderful
artist, Mehdi Saeedi, who is here.
Mehdi Saeedi is an internationally
known artist and designer based
in Philadelphia, who
was born in Tehran.
His aesthetics have become a
mainstay of design in many parts
of the world, especially regions
that use the Persian
and Arabic scripts.
His special focus and proficiency
is in typography and calligraphy,
which leads him to be an expert in
the shaping of letters and the form
of shapes, zoomographic
and graphic design.
Saeedi has taught in
Iranian universities,
as well as held international
workshops, to bring the beauty
of arts and graphic design to those
with different linguistic
backgrounds.
He exhibited his work in
more than 250 exhibitions
and by annual events worldwide,
and he has attended numerous local
and international competitions as a
jury member and also as a speaker.
In 2013, he founded
-- I'm sorry, in 2013,
he also founded the first
international exhibition
of type design is part of
Silver Cyprus the Third Biannual
of Iranian Graphic
Designers Society.
There are several publications
on his collections,
as well as selections
of his artwork.
The most recent one of these is
the 2013 published work titled Form
Contour to Calligraphy.
He is featured among 30 designers
in the second edition publication
of New Masters of Poster Design
that features the best poster
designers currently working all
over the world.
His name is also listed in
Megg's History of Graphic design.
Now I can go on and on and on, but
he has a page this big of awards,
and instead of taking time, I'll
just say that I see awards here
from Ukraine to Taiwan,
of course Iran,
a whole slew of different
countries and places
that he has been and won awards in.
Without taking any further
time, I would like to allow him
to show his art [foreign language
spoken], Medhi, please come on.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>>Mehdi Saeedi: Hello everyone.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming today.
I'm very glad to be here, and I want
to thank ot the Library of Congress,
who invited me and Mr.
Hirad, especially Mr. Hirad
and Dr. Keshavarz and
[inaudible] Committee,
Charuz [assumed spelling],
Mr. Charuz.
Okay, when I was little,
I wanted to be a singer.
Back then, I used to be good at it.
I had. I had completely forgotten
about it until one month ago,
I got a video for my birthday and I
was surprised to find little Mehdi
in that video, holding a
microphone and singing into it.
I want to show you the video.
Unfortunately, the
file doesn't work here.
So that was my dream back then,
and look what's happened to it.
Of course, I'm holding a microphone
right now, but I'm not singing.
I'm lecturing on graphic design.
People do not always live
out their childhood dream,
but I'm very happy to
be graphic designer.
However, these things turn out
differently for my older brother
who you see in the video.
He used to play with the camera
as a kid, and now he's one
of the best photojournalists
in Iran.
He works for [inaudible]
for the agency.
He was published in the
New York Times, LeMont,
and other famous magazines.
I'm going to show some of
his works during my lecture.
So anyway, actually, yeah,
this is it, and this is my mom.
We go back to the presentation.
Okay, I did not live
out my childhood dream,
but I found many links
between singing
and using a graphic designer.
Maybe that is why I will design
many posters for music festival.
In fact, my first professional
poster was designed
for the most important
music festival in Iran.
The poster was this poster.
The poster was so ingenious
back then, everyone wanted
to know who the designer was.
Another reason the poster
gained widespread attention was
that there are over 100,000
prints in cities all over Iran.
After designing that
poster, I wondered which part
of graphic design is
should focus on that.
First, to give me work prominence
in graphic design, and second,
I will make a career out of it.
It was then, I remember
something my professor said.
He told me if you want your work to
last, and if you want to gain money
and fame, you just have to do
your job and do it well with love,
as if you are not going to get paid.
I heard what I needed
heard from my professor.
I'm a good listener because
what I wanted required patience
and practice, requires a lot.
So my Middle East of
places I wanted to work.
For example, the Tehran Museum of
Contemporary Art, Academy of Art,
international film
and music festivals,
and cultural and arts centers.
After -- at first I went to the
Museum of Contemporary Art Tehran,
which is one of the most important
museums in Tehran in Iran.
After a series of meetings
and visits,
they offered me a commission,
but it was not an easy job.
The manager said they needed
a poster for an exhibition
for a traditional Chinese painter.
They didn't have any portrait
of her nor picture of her works.
They only had a short,
handwritten Persian text.
Here is the text.
Just this.
They gave me no information,
and to make matters worse,
they wanted to design
an invitation card
for the next day, just next day.
One day. And I started
working right away.
The first things I did
was draw a vertical frame
that reflected the
atmosphere East Asian art.
Then I use the image
on the Internet.
The image, because the
main element of the poster,
but I feel like I needed
another element.
So I began to design the title
of the exhibition in Farsi.
I decided to rotate
the Persian letters,
so that they remind people
to Chinese characters.
I worked nonstop to
design the poster.
This is a result of what I
design in less than 24 hours.
The funny things is that designing
the title for that poster led
to the create of the
new Persian font.
This is a start of, I want to, you
know, trying to design a typeface,
Farsi type, based on
the Chinese characters.
As you may know, the Persian letters
alphabet consists of 32 letters,
and it is written from
the right to the left.
The image of the right shows
the separated Persian letters.
In the middle, you can see
all of the connected letters.
The last images shows the
sample of the work AGI,
which is a type with the new font.
The creation of this
form led to the series
of new works that I
want to show you.
This poster for Turning Point
for the Century British sculpture
of the Tehran Museum
of Contemporary Art.
This poster of exhibition
of selected work
by French artist Armando
Pierre Fernandez
at the Museum of Contemporary art.
This poster was designed
for honoring the famous
Iranian writer [inaudible].
I designed the writer's face
by considering the sentence he
wrote just before his death.
"I'm going to see you
on Judgment Day."
And surrealistic atmosphere,
as most of his work.
The first meeting
for the introducing the Tehran
Cultural Personality of the Year.
Proverb, the proverb.
When is the romance due?
At this point, clients were
getting attracted to my work,
but I didn't want my
work to be repetitive.
So after creating the font, you
just sell, I worked on new fonts.
I started to do sketches, and
finally, I create my second font.
This is the first thing's actually
I did with this font was used it
in the photo, you know,
for the poster,
invitation part, and book design.
I also used the font
on the wall clock.
After that, I tried to
use Persian calligraphy
because I think it is the most
important artistic element in Iran.
So I added modern and formalistic
calligraphy, not traditional style,
to my work like this,
one of the sketches
of the poster Iranian Spring.
This poster, part of exhibition
of Iranian art in Paris
and title Iranian Spring.
These images, these
images are a calendar
of calligraphy painting
on paperboard.
This is a book cover for
Chefs Like Grandmas by one
of the great [inaudible]
of the [inaudible],
and these are the images
from the inside of the book.
Okay, the late [inaudible] was one
of the most famous
sculptor from Iran.
I designed a poster with the
typography that expresses his work
and also also his physical
appearance.
As you can see, he's a big guy.
The color and texture of the
poster are also associated
with his sculpture.
This is the book cover was done
for Persian [inaudible] Proverb.
I'm in Love.
This is the title actually.
I designed his work to honor
Turkish poet Yunus Emre.
His poetry is romantic and minimal.
In this poster, I use
the word [foreign word],
meaning in Persian, love in Persian.
Since his poems were minimalistic,
I eliminated the word
[foreign word] itself,
and keep the five dots instead.
As you see, this work very close
to formalistic calligraphy,
pure from without any
specific shapes.
Later I thought, how can
I convey Iranian symbols,
and at the same time,
attracted not Iranian audiences?
I wanted my work to be
understandable for all
of the people, not just for Iranian.
You know, this image is most
important, you know, visual element.
Yet you can communicate
with everyone.
Even when a child sees a picture,
he or she can easily understand it
or consider people who don't
know how to read and write.
Even those people can read images.
Therefore, I did some research on
traditional calligraphy and image.
I found my answer to all of my
questions in looking at work
from 14th century,
when calligraphers used the
writing symbol in the pictorial form
and had a static religious
objective.
That was just what
I was looking for.
It was both calligraphy and images.
Something that everyone
could understand,
but here, the size a challenge.
If I were to do the same things,
it wouldn't be considering new art.
So I explored new metals.
The results are I want to show you.
These images are related
to the the sketches
for the poster nine Iranian
graphic design [inaudible],
and this is the final works.
Yes, this [inaudible], and on
the cover, Ecotimes Magazine,
for honoring 400 years
of publication,
novel Don Quixote and
also billboard.
For international music festivals.
[foreign name] is one of the
most outstanding Iranian musician
and calligrapher of
the 13th century.
Since he was known as a
creator of the timbre,
an Iranian musical instrument
and a great calligrapher,
I tried to design his -- because
people were playing timbre
by calligraphic writing
with his name.
Shiraz, Persian paradise.
It was designed for the Shiraz Art
and Cultural Exhibition
in the France.
This poster involved in an
exhibition of the paintings
of three Iranian women
entitled Three Iranian Looks.
This is sketches of Garden of Iran.
The theme of the poster in Garden of
Iran, patience, wisdom, new vision.
It was designed for an
exhibition with same title
for the Tehran Museum
of Contemporary Art,
and this is the final work.
[inaudible] is at the well bottom.
This work was designed based
on concept of Iranian proverb
that means when a person
creates a problem for others,
he himself will be troubled later.
The [inaudible] Festival.
This is a poster for the
[inaudible] Festival.
[inaudible] is one of the
most famous Persian poets
who wrote many [inaudible].
He's also close friend of the Rumi.
Eastern, my exhibition in
Missouri of State University.
Rumi 800th Birthday Celebration.
The poster was [inaudible].
I want to show you the
process of my work here.
You can see, and this is a final.
2012 years, a dragon.
Iranian traditional
music in Australia.
The First International Conferences
of Architecture and Globalization,
a combination of architecture
in Iran and Japan.
This poster was designed for
the Campaign Supporting Music.
For music concert in church,
Song of Solomon and the angel.
Book cover for the
Nobel Rise of the Shams.
After my cooperation
with the cultural centers
and getting better understanding
of society in which I had lived,
I began to think about politics and
social issues where I was living.
Yes, Iran.
Can you tell me what comes to your
mind when you hear the name of Iran?
I'm asking you.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
The [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Poetry, yes.
Others? [inaudible] yes.
Very positive things.
Good. First, let's look at the
Iranian from a tourist perspective.
This short film is
made by a Chinese woman
and shows her perspective
towards Iran.
>> [whispering] Baby,
still want to go to Iran?
[ Music ]
>> This is a best friend.
[ Laughter ]
[ Music ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Chanting ]
[ Music ]
>> Yeah, that's Iranian style.
>> When I hear Iran names, I
think about some certain things.
First, 7000 years.
Yes, 7000-years-old cultural
architecture and calligraphy.
Second Middle Eastern
oil and politics.
My realization were in
the line with, you know,
with the wars in Lebanon,
Afghanistan, and later Iraq,
and on the news, innocent
people getting killed.
My brother, who is the
photographer, who I told you
about in the beginning, used
the trouble to these countries.
He share his photos with us
before sharing them with the news.
Our feelings were differently
from what's the news of the TV
and radio were announcing.
There are some of my
brother's photo.
They had impact me and my art.
From then, I decided to fulfill
my duty as as a human toward --
to even taking place, and trying
to change perspective of society,
or at least, draw its
attention to these problems.
So I began to design topic
with where my own concern,
and I couldn't get
them out of my head.
This concern of mine
didn't have a client.
Most of them, because
90% of the social
and political wars are not
ordered by anyone as a job.
This poster is for the racism.
Child labor.
The word exploding.
In Iranian cultural
pomegranate is a symbol of life.
Here I likened the word pomegranate
and I used repetition of the letters
of the exploding word to show
the massive problem of the word
and its resulting pollution.
The pollution rise as a
word exploding inside.
AIDS [inaudible].
And God created men free.
Free thought for writing and
free election are a main element
of democracy.
This is [inaudible]
poster used [inaudible]
and understandable
symbols for the public.
It's designed in a way to involve
the audience in effect when faced
with this symbol of democracy
with the two black lines
and transparent paper layer, with
the title Democracy Does not Work,
covered one way, then
cover is removed
to show that democracy can work.
Poster of congress of
society [inaudible] in Iran.
This poster designed for
human rights conference
in Penn University.
I was asked by Police Bureau in Iran
to design a poster related
to police performance.
I spoke to different people
about the politics in general.
I conclude the most
complaint about inner city
and security of the night.
The Police Bureau consider
the slogan for the poster.
Police discipline,
security, turn quality.
I talked about two posters
with the one main idea.
In this first poster, I
shows the suggested slogan
in the bold, prominent way.
I choose this title
Police in The Day,
and the title of the second
one is Police at the Night.
Its background is black,
and we can't see any sign
of evidence of police.
In 2011, I had opportunity
to work in Germany,
and I create two projects.
The one project is about animal.
Every day, I saw iron bars installed
in shops, namely letters, panel,
and [inaudible] in way in my studio.
Since I have not seen
them in my country,
I wondered what was their use.
Then I asked shopkeeper about
them, and I heard sad response.
These iron bar are
for the silent pigeons
to pre-warn them for sitting there.
The interesting part was that I had
seen great demonstration in support
of animals, in which those
shopkeepers also participated.
The contradiction in this
behavior made me design a poster
for this issue.
In doing that, I tried to
use the [inaudible] letters
with the [inaudible]
pigeon control on them
of my poster entitled
Be Kind to All Animals.
And this is a second
project I had in Germany.
This is an installation entitled
Racism Crushes the Human Spirit.
I used image of African face on
poster board, crumbling its features
to represent the effect of racism,
and underscored with a piece
of writing in Persian,
"All Humans are Equal."
Keeping black and white then.
The poster was displayed in the
darker room along with the mass
of thousand pieces of the
crumbled paper on the ground.
Each with a image of
the different face along
with the anti-racist
slogans we routinely heard
but don't really think
about with much [inaudible].
[inaudible] can unfold the
paper symbolically trying
to undo the damage of racism.
I want to show you that.
What's happened for installation.
[ Music ]
Yes.
Ladies and gentleman, I
represent a new symbol of peace.
This is my last poster.
I want to show you the
project recently I worked
about the Shahnameh, and I
want to show you how I work,
you know, based on the subject.
[ Owl Hooting ]
[ Crickets Chirping ]
[ Background Discussion ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Trumpets Sounding ]
[ Horse Neighing ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Music ]
[ Silence ]
>> After living and working much
of his life in Iran as an artist,
Mehdi felt the need for a
new cultural environment
which can stimulate
his creative process
and inspire his new body of work.
[ Background Discussion ]
He started his inspirational journey
by living short periods of time
in Slovenia, France, and Germany,
and ultimately, he decided to move
to a country where diverse cultures
and nationalities could
be found in one place.
Consequently, he decided to
move to the United States.
[ Music ]
Immigration has triggered a
new perspective in his work,
building on his existing
accomplishments
in Persian calligraphy
and graphic design.
[ Music ]
Medhi hails from a culture
and ancient civilization
where it's collective history,
art, and language has led him
to create artwork, propelling
him into being recognized
as a distinguished Iranian artist.
According to him, one of the
more important challenges is
to apply Persian script
and at the same time,
connecting with an audience who
does not share the same literature
and transcript.
[ Music ]
The 10th-century poet, Ferdowsi,
is considered by many to be one
of the greatest Persian
poets to have ever lived.
One of Ferdowsi's seminal works,
Shahnameh, or The Book of Kings,
is an enormous poetic opus
and is the national epic
of the Persian speaking world.
[ Music ]
The Shahnameh tells the mythical
and historical past of Iran
and the creation of the world
up to Islam entering Iran
in the 7th century, and
is a splendid example
of how culture moves
across time and space,
all of which has been inspiration
behind Medhi's new series.
The most well-known character
of The Book of Kings, Rostam,
represents paladin, or a moral
as well as physical champion,
and symbolizes the collective
knowledge of Iranians.
He utilized various techniques
that include calligraphy ink,
acrylic paint, digital
print, and also mixed media.
In this new series, which
consists of 10 pieces,
he illustrates the most well-known
characters of The Book of Kings.
What makes this series even
more unique is the complexity
of the works as metal ink was
used to add texture to the images.
These images correlate with images
of battle scenes that are based
on the descriptions from
the book and inspired
by its miniature paintings.
Ultimately, the main element
of the piece is a mirror.
Medhi believes that a piece
that demonstrates an artist's
vigorous eye for beauty,
should have hidden ideas
behind it and be presented
by different creative method.
[ Music ]
Based on this, he's
been pursuing a method
by which the completed work
expressed something new
by creating images using
Persian calligraphy,
whether it would be mixed media on
canvas or through graphic design.
[ Music ]
His work is focused on the
balance of images, and thus,
he has introduced a mirror
as the symbol of reality,
to strengthen the denotation
of symmetry.
The Book of Kings is a mirror of
Iran's ancient myths and legends
with accounts of major
events in its past.
In this new series,
Medhi tries to emphasize
that even though the mirror
is the symbol of reality,
it does not always
reflect what is real.
[ Music ]
At first glance, when one
looks at the canvas alone,
the viewer perceives an ambiguous
and somewhat abstract image.
However, after viewing both,
the artwork with its reflection
from the right angle, the
characters become vividly apparent.
>>Mehdi Saeedi: Thank
you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: That was
a brilliant, brilliant show.
Thank you everyone for coming.
I know that we are at 1, but
I would like to allot him
at least five minutes of questions.
Feel free to ask any questions,
and I would direct it to him,
and please speak loudly, since
there's only on microphone here.
Go ahead.
>> You said that when you saw
that 10th century image made
out of calligraphy, you
had found the answer
to all the questions [inaudible].
I mean, I know calligraphy
is beautiful and [inaudible],
but it kind surprised me, because it
seemed like you're always exploring
and going to new things [inaudible].
So how did that to suddenly become
like the answer to everything?
>>Mehdi Saeedi: Actually, I
was looking for some way to,
as I told you in the lecture, to
communicate with the audience.
You know, the image's
biggest and important part.
So based on that, I'm just trying
to find something different
and somethings new, but I
don't want to, you know,
forget my culture and background.
That's because, as I told you, the
Iranian calligraphy, it's, you know,
it's the biggest things
in our culture.
So based on that, I just thought,
"How can I use [inaudible] use
the Persian and images together?"
And after that, I found it, you
know, this way, and after that,
I tried to, in a graphic
design, because graphic design,
you have to communicate
with your audience.
So based on that, for example, if I
want to work for a music festival,
I'm just trying to writing.
I made a picture based
on the calligraphy,
and at the same times can
communicate with the audience,
and also, you know, you
can see and you can feel
about somethings about the music.
Yes, yes. Any questions?
Okay, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> [inaudible].
Is there anyway you
can get [inaudible].
Do you have an exhibit or
anywhere you can [inaudible].
>>Mehdi Saeedi: Yes, actually, I had
an exhibition, but unfortunately,
something bad happen to the
gallery or something like that.
It's canceled for, you know, I had
an exhibition in the Alex Gallery,
in September 2nd to 13th, but
unfortunately, canceled, yes.
Yeah, I hope in the new
show in the, you know,
in the here again or another state.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
I don't know actually.
Could you please repeat that?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
No. I don't know, actually.
Maybe someone --
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yes, yes, sure, yes, yes.
>> Oh, okay.
>>Mehdi Saeedi: Yeah, of course.
Of course.
Yes, my website is Mehdi
Saeedi, www.MehdiSaeedi.com
without any space between.
>> Okay, thank you so much.
>> Mehdi Saeedi: Thank you.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank you again.
Thank you very much for coming.
This is a wonderful program.
Thank you.
Have a wonderful day.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.